Thanks to Incogni for sponsoring today's episode
Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory the show that's also having its main character recast
Wubba-dub-dub am I right oh
Sorry about that had a Lee in my throat today
We're talking about Rick and Morty gotta be real with you and all the craziness that was 2023
I almost missed that Rick and Morty came back
But now that I've got a chance to sit down and actually binge through the whole thing
I gotta admit that these have got to be some of the best episodes that the team has ever delivered. Okay, tough problem
Definitely a spicy meatball, but we can fix it including some huge moments of closure for these characters
Thank you for visiting the fear hole Morty your fear of relying on Rick has been delicious
We even wrap up some major stories that previously probably would have been milked for entire seasons
I threatened why not just do it because using a weapon like this doesn't get you left alone
Morty think I want a bunch of vengeful summers coming after me seriously though ** you don't come after me
It won't go well. But you know me sure the new seasons out. We have some laughs
We shed some tears
But now it's time to do what we love to do at the end of every season of Rick and Morty sit down and analyze
The season's theme look at this batch of episodes and try to figure out what they were trying to tell us
What was the thesis of this year? In case you missed our season 6 Rick and Morty theories?
We charted out that Rick was clearly on an arc of healing of
Confronting the grief that he felt over losing his original wife and daughter and trying to move forward with a new found family
What's more season 6 started to dabble with this idea of dissatisfaction where we watch as everyone who gets what they want are ultimately left
Empty and unhappy realizing that getting what you want sometimes isn't exactly what you need. Season 7 though
It takes these themes and ratchets them up to the next level
We see the climax of these character arcs about grief and dissatisfaction
and it shows us the
Consequences of the two ways that you can deal with grief through good healing and bad healing and through these stories
I believe that we can actually pinpoint who's gonna be the next big antagonist for Rick and Morty to face in the coming seasons
That's right loyal theorists
We are in the process of witnessing the birth of the next big Rick and Morty story arc and it shows us who's gonna be
The big bad facing off against the family from the very first episode. Open up your portals friends
It's time to jump in now if you miss season 7 to Rick and Morty
I highly recommend that you go and give it a watch
It provides some of the best episodes of the series period but it also gives us some of the most Rick and Morty esque
Ideas ever to be put to screen
I'm talking about planets full of people who turned a spaghetti when they die Rick and Jerry fusing together into one super being
Generation-long wars between letters and numbers fronted by Ice-T himself
But on top of all the fun adventure of the week stories season 7 also brings together and wraps up some of the show's longest
Running plot threads the biggest ones being Rick prime and evil Morty after spending his entire adult life
hunting down the man that killed his family the reason Rick is the way that he is Rick and Morty finally are able to
Confront Rick prime and with the help of evil Morty of all people they wind up winning
Evil Morty serves Rick prime up hogtied on a silver platter and then leaves and so of course mind overtaken by rage Rick goes ham
Killing Rick prime with his bare hands and a splatter a spaghetti sauce so brutal that it goes well beyond the point of YouTube
monetization. At first glance this seems like it should be the big climax of the series
I mean the show's bringing in four of its biggest players and letting them duke it out
Ending in the death of what's arguably Rick and Morty's main villain
But with the primary antagonist now off the board the real villain of this series can appear Rick's emptiness in the wake of killing Rick
Prime Rick feels nothing he realizes that completing this lifelong mission of vengeance hasn't really healed the part of him
That's been aching for years
He was given a motivation to track down Rick prime and kill him believing that this would be the magical thing that would help him
Feel better the magical thing that could potentially bring Diane back
But now without that target to distract himself Rick has to sit there with his pain knowing that he can never really undo this loss
This man the smartest man in the galaxy who can heal any wound who has taken down God who has brought himself back from the brink
Of death now has to confront the one thing that he can't fix the one thing that he can't just science into submission
And what's worse is that Rick prime made sure to twist the knife on his way out letting Rick know that he used a powerful
Super weapon known as the Omega device to erase Diane from the entirety of the multiverse no matter where or when Rick goes he can
Never ever get Diane back. But perhaps the most interesting thing about this episode was its placement in the season
It's episode 5 right in the middle you'd think that this would be the sort of thing that they would save as an epic climax
To the season, but it's not because putting it there would miss the point entirely. The battle
That's the centerpiece of Rick and Morty isn't against Rick prime. It was never against Rick prime. It's against yourself
It's about finding a healing for your own emotional scars. The death of Rick prime in the middle of the season allows the back five
Episodes to answer the really important question then: was any of this worth it? Sure Rick got what he wanted vengeance
But did it actually do anything to heal him clearly not in a way that left him satisfied all in all it was bad
Healing its surface level at best it leaves Rick arguably in a worse place than when he first started and it requires a now
Directionless Rick to find new purpose and thankfully for him
He has all the necessary ingredients for good healing right in front of him his family and especially his grandkids in the episode Rick Fending
Your Mort Morty checks in on a clearly depressed Rick and does his best to make him feel better by cashing in his Morty
Adventure cards encouraging Rick to take him on another adventure just to get him out of his funk. I'm not right now Morty
Definitely next week though
A while now buddy, so I think I'm gonna give you a little nudge by cashing in a few of these bad boys
And in the episode wet kuat a Mordecai summer Rick admits that he respects summer partially because her headstrong personality reminds him of Diane
I treat you like an equal because I respect you.
Reminds me of your grandmother. All of this comes to a head in the season 7 finale fear no more
It's probably one of the top 5 episodes
The show has ever produced which sees Rick and Morty discovering a mysterious fear hole in a Denny's
Bathroom a hole with the ability to manifest the greatest fears of anyone that jumps inside. Though
they initially decide to leave it alone Morty rushes back in and jumps down the hole with Rick following after to save him
They both fight off monsters until they're both able to escape from the hole later when they arrive home
Diane appears out of a portal and Rick and Morty soon realized that they're still stuck inside the fear hole Rick thinks
It's because Morty's afraid of losing him to Diane Morty thinks that his greatest fear is watching Rick die
Intent to get them both out of the fear hole Morty continually faces his fears in an attempt to overcome them
But nothing works until Rick mentions that Morty is irreplaceable. Come on, you're irreplaceable
This makes Morty realize that this Rick he isn't real Rick never entered the hole after him Morty's greatest fear is his
Overreliance on Rick finally overcoming this true fear Morty escapes the hole awakening to find Rick watching him from the outside
This entire experience is a massive step forward for Morty
But it also winds up showing how far the positive healing has been for Rick. After Morty mentions that he saw Diane inside the hole
Rick runs back to it for a moment
It looks like he's gonna jump in to try and desperately hold on to Diane in any way that he can just like we've seen
Him try to do over and over and over again in the series
But then Rick stops instead of jumping in the hole
He takes out a photo of Morty from his wallet tacks it up onto the wall of victors people who escaped from the hole
It's an act of pride in his grandson this person who represents Rick's future instead of just always going back to his past
Rick is showing us that he's moved beyond just the empty bad healing that he'd been pursuing this entire time and is starting to work
Towards true good healing deeper healing and that's not the only thing that can help Rick heal
So can the sponsor of today's episode Incogni.
I don't know if this has ever happened to you
But sometimes I'll be doing some Google searches while researching for a theory and then like clockwork a day or two later
I'm flooded with ads about that exact same topic or I'll sign up for a newsletter for a store that I really like
And then suddenly get sent a bunch of spam emails out of nowhere
This sort of thing happens because there are literally
Thousands of companies out there whose sole purpose is to collect your personal data and then sell or trade that data for their own profit
They include your full name your email and home address even your phone and social security number
They might even have access to your secret Szechuan sauce recipe
Thankfully if you ask these data brokers to delete your information, they legally have to do it
But the bad news is that it would take an average person
Years of time to do it by themselves
time that you should be using doing things that you actually love to do like going on adventures through time and space with your
Favorite grandson and this is where Incogni comes in
See, it's literally Incogni's job to do all that work for you with your permission
They can track down all of these brokers and make sure that your data is off the market
We've partnered with Incogni in the past and let me tell you the before and after of my email inbox and text messages is
Huge actually went back to take a look at how it was going and they were still fighting for me completing almost 120 removal
Requests since late August that saved me by their calculation literally 88 hours of my time
And it's also made a noticeable difference in the amount of spam that's clogging up my emails
Basically, I haven't had to worry about getting these weird newsletters or shady offers at all
So if you want to protect your personal data and keep your private information private
Please go to Incogni.com/film theory and then use our code of film theory to get 60% off their annual plan
once again, that's Incogni and
cog and I dot com slash
Film Theory or you know, save yourself the hassle and just click the link in the description because it is so much easier that way
You can get a great deal on their great service. Thanks again to Incogni for sponsoring today's video
Now let's jump back in to the multiverse of Rick and Morty for the first half of the season
The show really focuses on the concept of bad healing touching more characters than just Rick
For example in the episode Air Force Wong
We see how President Curtis responds to a breakup by hijacking a hive mind hoping to see his approval ratings hit a hundred percent
Cuz if he can't have the approval of the woman he loves well the rest of the United States will have to do
This is the perfect example of trying to use external approval as a method for healing
Something that ends up hurting both the person trying to heal as well as everyone around him similarly in the season premiere how poopy got
His poop back. We see how Mr. Poopybutthole is dealing with the divorce and let's say it's not going too well
I agree, Beth, I'm a piece of garbage. Instead of letting go of his ex-wife moving on and creating a healthy new direction for his life to go in to support his
Son, Mr. Poopybutthole goes on a bender with Rick and Hugh Jackman ending up kidnapping poor poopy jr
The way he's trying to quote-unquote
He'll here is by holding on to everything that he lost to the point that it ends up hurting the people that he cares about
The most sound familiar. Well, it should it's what Rick's been doing to the Smith family for the past six seasons
As you'd expect this sort of selfish coping ultimately doesn't turn out all that well for poopy
She's in for episode three. Let's go. This is exactly what Rick would have done earlier in the series. Mr
Poopybutthole is what Rick could have become but he doesn't because of his family and all the good healing that happens
After he kills Rick Prime you want some proof
All you have to do is look into the back half of season 7 episodes and you get your answer
For example both those episodes I mentioned earlier where Rick leans on Morty and summer to positively heal they come after he kills Rick Prime
In Rise of the Numericons we see the Alphabetrians and Numbericons heal a rift between their people
That's lasted for generations all because two of them realized that they weren't all that different with the help of Rick
I think when we started getting it on that amulet showed us the truth of our origin father in Mort Ragnarok
Rick starts the episode trying to take advantage of Bigfoot to gain power enough
So that Bigfoot literally wants to kill Rick over and over but by the end of it all he finds common ground with Bigfoot and the
Two part ways on good terms. Why are we at the woods?
Time to go on home big fella. Oh
Okay, you're free
And of course the fear hole represents the end of that growth arc
But my favorite example that I want to call attention to actually comes from the episode right before Rick kills Rick Prime
In it we see a miniature version of this entire arc that Rick's on in the season standout episode
That's a Morty we see a planet where those who choose to end their own life have their internal organs turned to spaghetti
Yep, that is really the plot and trust me. They somehow find a way to make it work
Their cortisol increases the starch content in their bloodstream changing their intestines into one long spaghetti noodle
The most messed up part of this whole thing is that the spaghetti is delicious and everybody wants to eat it despite realizing where it
came from
This ends up turning into big business for the planet who then encouraged more and more people to cut their lives short all for their
Own profits truly it is a messed up idea
But it's a brilliant commentary on how sometimes we can only see people as numbers a source for content feeding on their misery and self-destruction
Literally finding their pain delicious. So we continue to inflict it and feed off of it
So then where does the healing come in?
Well at the end of the episode Rick and Morty broadcast the entire life of an old man showing his pain
But also his ups his downs his loves his heartbreak his humanity and afterwards. No one can stomach the spaghetti anymore
They suddenly see the people on this planet is more than just content
They see the beauty of the humanity in this situation how relatable it all is and suddenly
Everyone is able to heal as for Rick. It's the seed
That's the beginning of his choice to move forward in a healthy way one that becomes all the more powerful given how far he's come
So that's everything that happened the season
But obviously it wouldn't be a Rick and Morty theory if we didn't also try to figure out where things are headed to next and
I believe that it all comes down to this little guy. I don't believe it's any coincidence that this season was bookended by mr
Poopybutthole in fact these episodes show just how far in the opposite direction
He's growing from Rick and the Smith's not only did we see him try to kidnap his own child as I talked about before
But in the stinger the last episode mr. Poopy butthole follows the darkest of paths killing and replacing a separate mr.
Poopybutthole from another universe to replace him to live his happy life with his happy family
Sounds a lot like something Rick used to do huh finding a new universe to start over in when everything falls apart in his life
Resetting things back to a status quo so he never has to grow never has to face his own pain
What's more the series is gonna need itself a new antagonistic force now that Rick Prime is dead and evil Morty is off the table
That is the role mr.
Poopybutthole is gonna be taken here in a similar way to how Rick Prime was the Rickest Rick the person that most embodied
The worst of Rick's traits earlier in his life mr.
Poopybutthole is gonna become the healed Rick's opposite someone who's felt a lot of the same pain
But goes about healing from it in the worst ways possible hurting everyone around him
He'll embody all the bad healing that Rick himself used to embrace in the end Rick's ultimate test isn't his own healing
But whether he's able to teach others his best friends how to heal, but hey
That's just a theory a film theory and cut!